michael je te connais depuis que tu es
tout petit tu as dont tu l'a toujours
eue s'il existe un remède à la maladie
tu le trouveras
il ya des années que je devrais être
mort
si je suis encore en vie c'est pour
régler ça j'ai une maladie du sang rare
je manque de temps et à
ce pourrait être ma dernière chance
tu me jacques quelque chose c'est quoi
ça
on pas dire que ce soit très légal
je n'ai pas envie de voir souffrir
encore plus ça pourrait bien guérir
[Musique]
à quel prix
michael
qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'étais mourant
aujourd'hui je me sens plus vivant que
jamais
suis plus fort et plus rapide
j'ai le pouvoir des colocations
et un besoin incontrôlable de consommer
du centre
quel moment doit-on s'arrêter
quand on veut soigner un mal
c'est quand le remède
et pire que la maladie
michael morbius thomas s'est tu et les
gentils 1